عمرو عمرو حلبي هلا سمعتم اصدار الترددات
او تداعيات لهذا الزلزال الذي قيل بان
مركزه في سمندل قريبه من انطاكيا
هو اصلا جمال في الحقيقه ضرب ايضا من شمال
غرب سوريا هنا الهزه نحن هنا شعرنا بها
بوضوح ايضا استمرت لنحو 20 ثانيه وكان
الزلزال قويا
لا اعرف اذا كان اذا كنت استطيع ان اقول
انه نفس الزلزال الاول لكنه زلزال قوي
والناس في الشارع هرعت الناس الى الشوارع
هنالك حاله كبيره من الفوضى نحن كنا
متجهين من مدينه اعزاز باتجاه مدينه عفرين
حتى نرصد في النشرات المقبله اوضاع
النازحين لكن على في الطرقات
شعرنا بالهزه
وتوقفنا في على يمين على قارعه الطريق
وراينا حاله الهلع الكبيره ايضا بين الناس
الناس كلها غادرت الابنيه ونزلت الى
الشوارع الناس الان في سياراتها خصوصا في
قلب المدن في مدينه اعزاز ونحن الان على
مشارف مدينه اعزاز بريفي حلب الشمالي كل
مدن الشمال شمال سوريا شعرت بهذه الهزه
هنالك انباء لكنها غير مؤكده بعد عن عن
انهيار ابنيه سكنيه او على الاقل بناء
واحد في مدينه جنديرس بريفيه عفرين وهي
المدينه التي كان لها كان لها النصيب
الاكبر من الاضرار في الزلزال الاول هنالك
انباء ايضا عن اصابات وقعت
وايضا لحقت بمدنيين جراء هذا الزلزال الذي
حصل والذي وقع قبل قليل مدينه اعزاز اعزاز
بريف حلب الشمالي بعد الزلزال مباشره
شاهدنا انقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن معظم
المدينه
الناس الان كما ذكرت هي في حاله هل نحن
راينا كذلك سيارات الاسعاف وراينا فرق
الدفاع المدني تتوجه بسياراتها هل هنالك
معلومات مؤكده لدى الدفاع المدني بان
هنالك ابنيه قد انهارت ما توصلنا اليه حد
حتى هذه اللحظه وحتى هذه الدقائق بان
الدفاع المدني الاسعاف تقوم بالتاكد من
عدم وجود اصابات بين المدنيين او او حتى
تتاكد ان كان هنالك ابنيه منهاره او لا
عموما هذه هي دقائق الفوضى الاولى بعد هذا
الزلزال الثاني او الزلزال الجديد فلنقل
لانه هنالك عشرات الهزات الارتداديه التي
حصلت لكن هذا الزلزال القوي الذي حصل الان
نحن نعيش الان حاله الفوضى التي تعقب هذا
الزلزال الناس في الشوارع فرق الدفاع
المدني وفرق الاسعاف تتاكد من عدم وجود
مصابين وتتاكد من عدم وجود ابنيه ومنازل
منهاره وفق الانباء الاوليه كما ذكرت فان
هنالك بناء سكني قد انهار في مدينه جنديرس
ولم نتاكد حتى الساعه ان كان هنالك اصابات
بعد انهيار هذا المبنى السكني لكن عموما
الزلزال كان قويا في هذه المنطقه من شمال
غربي سوريا وهي نفس المناطق التي تاثرت
بالزلزال الاول جمال